le procès s'est ouvert ce matin celui de
clément et gilet jaune frappé au sol par
un policier le 18 janvier 2020 en marge
d'une manifestation accusé lui même de
violence envers les forces de l'ordre
les réquisitions sont tombées je suis au
tribunal de paris
on retrouve quatre techniques le jeune
homme a été condamné à six mois de
prison assortis d'un sursis simple
puisse 2000 euros en réparation pour
l'un des policiers 600 euros pour un
autre et plus de 15000 euros à l'agent
de l'état pour l' incapacité temporaire
de travail d'un policier le jeune homme
jugé aujourd'hui était accusé d'avoir
lancé des bouteilles et des pierres sur
des policiers blessant un brigadier à
l'épaule cela n'a pas été retenu
finalement il est accusé aussi d'avoir
donné des coups à un policier et surtout
d'avoir craché du sang au visage d'un
autre policier en criant qu'il était
séropositif c'est cela qui lui a valu la
peine de prison avec sursis et la lourde
indemnisation on écoute l'avocat de deux
des policiers qui ont porté plainte
mais si une peine assez satisfaisante
parce que le tribunal a fait la part des
choses il l'a relaxé partiellement sur
certaines des infractions pour les
qualités poursuivi il l'a condamné pour
les violences commises sur mes clients
et qu'on peut voir d'ailleurs à travers
les images et la peine d'avertissement
est tout à fait normal je dirais six
mois de prison avec sursis pour ce genre
de passage à l'acte et de comportements
de violence envers les policiers au sein
d'une manifestation parce que je
rappelle que mon client
malgré cette vidéo où on a fait dire ce
qu'on a voulu dire mais qui
correspondait pas à la réalité parce que
toujours une question d'angle et de ce
qui peut se passer avant et après et
même pendant mon client lui bénéficier
d'un classement sans suite parce que les
coups qu'on peut voir sont parfaitement
légitimes et justifiées
alors que ce que ne disait pas la
défense ça m'intéressait et qu'on a pu
voir une chieuse mans sur ces vidéos
c'est qu'il a craché dans la bouche au
visage de mon client cet incident avait
défrayé la chronique car lors de son
interpellation le jeune homme a été
filmée recevant des coups au visage
alors qu'il était maintenu au sol coups
donnés par l'un des policiers qui a
porté plainte
la vidéo était devenue virale du fait de
sa violence elle avait même suscité une
réaction du ministre de l'intérieur de
l'époque christophe castaner et à la
barre le jeune homme a reconnu le coup
sur le casque d'un policier pour
défendre un manifestant interpellé mais
pour le reste il a contesté
on le voit sur les vidéos être matraque
et saigné abondamment
ensuite il dit avoir été menacés de mort
insulté pas soigner ce qui explique
selon lui un unique rachat sur le
policier par peur de versions
contradictoires mais la justice a
tranché en le relaxant de certains chefs
d'inculpation mais en le jugeant
coupable des violences